well good afternoon it's uh 1 30 and
eastern time i'm kind of nervous this is
my first webinar so i hope all goes
quite well
um
so just a little bit about myself i'm an
associate professor of biomedical
engineering at the university of
virginia
and i'm interested in target
identification for
delivery molecularly targeted delivery
of therapeutic agents
and also
doing early detection for various
cancers
the techniques that i use are pretty
widely applicable across a number of
diseases cardiovascular neural cancer
all kinds of cancer but since i'm mostly
focused or the main biology i focus on
is pancreatic cancer i thought i'd go
ahead and
just give you an application or an
example of using the techniques
so just a little bit uh if you would
hold your questions to the end
and use the
writing tool
to submit the questions then i'll read
them online and then answer them if i
can
and then also this is continuing
education eligible so if you need ce
credit
then go ahead and click on whatever
button you're supposed to click on i
think it's pretty
self-explanatory
so with that i'll go ahead and get
started and then take your questions at
the end
so a little bit about the application so
when we go ahead and we start to design
agents so think about
designing agents i'm an engineer so
that's what i do is design things uh we
first start to think about the
application and the first thing we do is
we talk to the end user and in this case
it's the clinician and so you have to
have an understanding of what the
clinicians are going to want
um and and what they're going to need
and use in order to make it applicable
um so in the case of pancreatic cancer
it's
it hardly cracks the top 10 in terms of
estimated new cases so you can see i'm
going to draw on the whiteboard which i
think this is fantastic
pancreas cancer is right here it's it's
low
in
incidents in male and female but on the
other hand if you look at estimated
deaths from cancer it shoots up to the
number four leading cause of death due
to cancer in the u.s and it's estimated
that it's actually going to overtake the
other cancers in terms of death because
of the obesity epidemic and
other things so
it's a significant problem in the united
states and and abroad
um and again this is just replotting
this so if you look at the percentage of
death over incidents pancreatic cancer
has a five-year survival rate of roughly
only about six percent and so that's not
that's not really good so 96 or 94 of
patients will succumb to their illness
within five years
on average so 80 percent of
patients that
are
appear due to symptoms and they are
usually um
they are not eligible for surgery so
currently surgery is the only
is the only uh route for
for cure
um and so like i said 80 percent of
patients are not eligible for surgery
they're already metastatic when they
when they present and they come into the
clinic um the other 20 percent are
eligible for surgery they have a better
median survival time of about 15 months
if a patient is not eligible for surgery
that means survival time is about three
to six months however it is getting
better
there are new regimens for fear nox for
example that is that is making it a
better also approximate so there is some
strides but but still the five year silo
rate is really dismal so there's some
challenges to pancreatic cancer one is
the it like most cancers the
symptomatic nature of the disease
um
it's also difficult to image so where
clinicians uh in the community has made
incredible strides in cancer detection
or cancer treatment and cure has been in
early detection so the smaller you can
find it if you can find it in stage one
of course it's it's much easier to treat
and to cure
so breast cancer you have mammogram for
breast cancer colon cancer
those rates are in the 90
or greater percent and in fact the
american cancer society released a
statement saying that if
more people would go ahead and get the
screening that sixty percent of the
deaths due to colon cancer would be
prevented just by
increasing compliance with the screening
protocols
um
melanoma it's easy you can visualize it
so what all these things have in common
is they have
detection techniques that are relatively
cheap they're relatively easy relatively
non-invasive i know the bowel prep is
bad for
colon cancer but anyway
early detection and imaging pancreatic
is not just so easy so as you can see
from
from this diagram here's your pancreas
right here but right around the pancreas
you have the liver
uh you have the the stomach and the
spleen and these are all sorts of bowels
and things and so oh and the kidneys are
in the back so the pancreas lies right
in the middle there's no open lumen to
it and so endoscopic ultrasound is
typically what's used and it's dropping
an
endoscope down through the esophagus
into the stomach and then trying to
trying to image it but it's not it's not
so easy to detect and so what we're
starting to do is working on a way to be
able to do early detection of pancreatic
cancer now i have to say that imaging
text
tests are not going to be the first line
especially since the incident rate is so
low for pancreatic cancer um any even if
you've got a 99.9
sensitivity and specificity
the sheer number of people that you
would be screening you would have way
more false positives or false negatives
especially false positives which would
have a bigger workup
um then you would actually cure from
from the cancer and so what we're
looking at is using things so right now
we know certain things about
family
certain families uh and also high risk
factors new onset diabetes so people
that had normal that have a normal bmi
would just have neurons that diabetes
um
chronic pancreatitis is a a large risk
factor for pancreatic cancer and then as
serum testing comes online as serum
biomarkers are found
um then you would plug imaging into that
that clinical
paradigm you're always going to need to
image to determine extent of disease um
and to
to look at the disease the spread all of
that and so imaging plays an important
role in current clinical
diagnosis and current clinical
management
so with that pancreatic cancer is
deceptively deceptively homogeneous the
first mutation is a k-ras mutation
ninety-five percent of of people will
get a k-ras mutation however k-rest is a
terrible biomarker because it's up in a
lot of benign conditions so the
pancreatic intraepithelial neoplasm one
so panon one
those are not going to become cancer uh
in a person's lifetime or the the
likelihood of it when you detect it
would be low same thing with pan in two
and at that time so you get the classic
oncogene activation and k-ras you get
the loss of the tumor suppressors in p16
inc 4a
um and then by panning threes p19r p53
loss and all of these are 90 or greater
in patients and so it's like i said it's
pretty homogeneous but that doesn't mean
the disease is homogeneous there's a lot
of heterogeneity
in there
um panning threes are where you would
want to detect and also the cystic
lesion so on the right side of the ipmn
and the mcns
there's about a hundred thousand cases
of ipmns and they are monitored yearly
to determine whether or not
they're big enough or if they look
dysplastic
so they're monitored for that so being
able to tell
if the cyst has high grade dysplasia
versus low-grade dysplasia or cancer in
there would again help a lot in clinical
management
but understanding the disease
progression really makes it so that
mouse modeling can be done especially
since early tissues are so hard to come
by so if you want to be able to detect
it really early you want a marker that's
up in panon 3 not present in chronic
pancreatitis not present in normal not
present in pan in one or two which you
wouldn't want to
disturb because touching or messing with
the pancreas is
is pretty hazardous you can provoke
chronic pancreatitis or acute
pancreatitis there's a lot of things
that could go wrong
so working with mouse modelers uh nabil
bardisi and ron dupinho
when ron was at
dana farber he's now president of md
anderson they made a mouse model of
pancreatic cancer that has k ras knock
in
with an ink for a arc deletion and these
animals they they it's 100
penetrance you get consistent kinetics
they have the mutations and you can
isolate cells from different stages of
the disease so the pan in one normal
pan in three and also tumor and
metastatic tumor so it gives us a source
of tissue and cells that allow us to to
try to find biomarkers
and the other thing is is that i know
this is a mouse model and so when i show
you the screening tools we'll show i'll
show you that
we're always mindful about the fact i
mean there's no perfect way or perfect
system to do something and so we always
cross reference or validate on human
tissue and also mouse tissue because
we're going to do a lot of work in the
mouse models in order to bring it to the
clinic
so now becomes the question of okay well
what target should we go after so if
we're going to do molecular imaging and
we want to look at a molecule that will
help us distinguish benign from from
disease or benign from cancer what
molecule do you choose and so this
diagram is from roche
and i don't have any disclosures with
rose it's just a diagram that i got
uh it this just shows the metabolism it
doesn't even show all of the proteins
and the networks and the cells and so
how do you go ahead and decide what
target you should go after it becomes a
really difficult uh problem and it's
very very complex
and so
as an engineer i was thinking well what
if we
tell the target what it should be what
if we have design parameters or
parameters for the target and we say
okay we need it to be highly abundant
and we need it to be accessible so we
can deliver agents imaging or therapies
to it so it should be on the cell
surface it should be highly abundant and
it shouldn't be present in normal or
benign conditions well that's all well
and good kim but how do you go ahead and
do that
and what we are doing is we're using
viruses in order to be able to
identify these targets so a side part of
my lab is engineering um using biology
to engineer new materials and so the
viral kingdom is really easy to
understand they have very few proteins
on the proteins are not redundant so we
can go ahead and play with them so one
of these ways is to be able to engineer
um m13 which is a filamentous
bacteriophage for multiple displays so
phage display has been around since 1985
when it was published by george smith
from the university of missouri in
colombia
really brilliant idea and and
you can link genotype with phenotype and
this will become important for the uh
target identify identification a little
bit later but anyway we can get it to
display different things so we can get
it to
a target
so on this co protein this carries a
peptide that will target
cells and then these coke proteins we
can get them to complex different
nanoparticles and in this case it's iron
oxide so these iron oxides are super
paramagnetic so we can see them by mr
but they're also iron oxide so you can
heat them for therapy
but these are what the particles look
like on em and then after we incubate
these particles with the phage that are
displaying a tumor targeting peptide but
also a peptide that will
bind to these nanoparticles you get
decoration along the m13 virus that
makes a nanowire and these nanowires are
you can use them for mr so they change
relaxivity exactly how you would expect
and also they allow us to image the
tumor so what we are looking at here is
this is the tumor pre-injection
uh this is its mr signal and then
post-injection
we get a darkening and because it's iron
oxide and it's super paramagnetic it
darkens on t2 star weighted mr images
and what you'll notice about this tumor
is the heterogeneity so we're actually
picking up the heterogeneity of this
prostate tumor
so uh pretty exciting
uh but anyway we can make them smaller
so long versus short versions you can
really genetically engineer and control
these types of nanoparticles so we're
working on those in the lab
but really what we're doing so to go
back to this idea of identifying a
target with certain parameters we are
going to use phage display and so phage
display again george smith in 1985 he's
got some really nice papers that
describe this process and the
considerations of it but what you do is
to make a library and this is from new
england bio labs again no disclosures
i'm not paid by them
i do not get research funding from them
but you can engineer
uh
restriction sites so capin1 and eag-1 in
this
and then
you can have a length of amino acids
7 to 15 i think is the max you can do in
this system that have random
random base pairs and that makes a
library of 10 to the nine different
peptides that are being displayed on the
p3 coprotein of this particular phage
or virus and so that's what this looks
like so here is the p3 co-protein this
purple thing the peptides are being
displayed there's four to five copies so
each one of these has a peptide being
displayed in this case i'm using the
linear library you can use
disulfide constraints um and really play
with gibbs free energy for binding so
entropy and and all of that with
constraining conformations but really
why this is powerful is because genotype
equals phenotype so instead of having to
do
uh 10 to the nine different wells or 10
to the nine times six different wells
to do individual compounds for the right
binding parameters instead what you can
do is throw them all in the same well
let them bind wash away everything
doesn't bind and then just elute the
ones that have the specific parameters
so by playing with illusion conditions
you can really start to change
how tight the peptide will bind and then
if you have whole cells then only things
that the phage are accessible to will be
able to find you can even do this in
vivo and we've done a lot of screening
um and renata pascalini and erik
russellatti have pioneered this where
you can do in vivo and they show that
you can
distinguish that the blood vessels from
different organs based on the peptides
that bind and they call them vascular
zip codes
so anyway for this screen what we did is
we took those cells that we could
isolate from the mouse models incubated
the phage with the cell lines allowed
them to bind and internalize because
again i want to internalize and deliver
a drug potentially to these cells
let them bind wash away everything that
didn't bind
uh elude off the cell surface and then
lyse the cells and recover only the
things that were able to internalize
inside the cell and then we subtracted
against normal cells from the pancreas
so beta cells
acid or cells and our pancreatic ductal
uh epithelium
and in that way we remove everything
that's ubiquitously found
from there we get a list of peptides so
in this case we pick 30 plaques
get a list of peptides and then we go
ahead and do elisa binding on
target cells in this case
the cancer cells versus the control
ductal epithelium
and look at affinity versus specificity
so green means go the brighter the green
the better
the binding and that or the better the
number for that category so for example
clone 27 and clone 15 we went ahead and
did fluorescence
imaging so we incubated these with the
cells and then did microscopy
we could then take these cells digest
them
with trypsin and then do flow cytometry
and show the difference between tumor
cells and normal cells and then again
because we really want to
do this in patients we went and we
looked at human derived cancer cells
that are all pancreatic cancer and you
can see that the one clone versus a a
non-specific clone bound better to the
human cancer cells and to the mouse
cancer cells than to the normal
um cells or the unrelated colon so this
was specific and it cross-reacts with
both human and mouse so we can do all
the pre-clinical experiments that the
fda requires and then also use it in
human
so from there we make the phage into
imaging agents so again this is part of
our engineering biology we can do all
sorts of chemistry so in this case we
put fluorophores on these inject them
into the animals and then do intravital
microscopy so we make a laparoscopic
incision a small incision into the um
into the animal we put our mic our
microscope objective down onto the
pancreas and then we can image so here's
the wild type animal
this is the k-ras only animal and this
is the k rasp plus the tumor in this
case it's just a p53 deletion
mouse model and not the full p16 p19
on delete it's not the p
uh
19 p16 deletion and again that's part of
the validation to test out multiple
mouse models i don't want it to be
specific for one mouse model it should
be a universal phenomenon
and then after we're done imaging these
animals we can go ahead
euthanized them
and then do the histology so here's the
h e and then this is the anti-m13 so
it's binding to the tumor
in both cases
but not binding in the normal
we can also do other types of imaging
spect or pet imaging so instead of
putting a fluorophore or in addition to
putting a fluorophore we can put a
macrocyclic chelator that will allow us
in this case to chelate indium 111 for
respect or you can chelate zirconium for
pet um but what this allows us to do so
the phage are taking up non specifically
because they're big particles in the
liver and the spleen
and then the arrow is pointing to the uh
to the tumor in the pancreas so again
we're confirming before we make anything
else we are confirming that that peptide
is able to drive binding to the tumor
so from there we can conjugate them to
almost anything these are magnetic
fluorescent nanoparticles um they are mr
active again they're iron oxide coarse
so the a part of this is an iron oxide
core it's a there's a dextran
um coat around the iron oxide core
they're both magnetic and fluorescent
and we can inject these again do in vivo
optical imaging and what you're seeing
is here are the two here's the tumor um
in red but also we can look at the blood
vessels so by injecting a large
molecular weight dextran with a
different fluorophore we can look at in
this mouse model so again this is the
transgenic the extent of the vessels
with the tumor and in this case there's
there's a pretty good vascularization
which which
doesn't really reflect uh what happens
in the human
but then over here is a zoomed out image
um again this is the
in in intravital in vivo imaging you can
see all of the tumor so that's one of
the caveats of this mouse model is
there's multiple foci of the tumor but
what's also exciting is this individual
looking at and imaging individual cells
of the the tumor streaming through the
pancreas stroma
so it's really nice to start studying
kinetics and such using these techniques
so from there we started making the
clinically relevant agent in this
incarnation as a spect agent we have a
pet agent coming soon and this is to
make it completely chemically
synthesized so it's a tetrameric
structure so there's four of those
peptides identified with a macrocyclic
chelater that will chelate indium or
zirconium or whatever we want in this
case it's indium 111
we get the synthesized
gmp by a just peptide company
and then they send it to us
and then what we do is we inject it and
we can do spec ct imaging and what i'm
going to show you is a movie in the
upper right is the tumor and then you
can see the kidneys which this is being
eliminated by but it gives us a 3d
rendering of of this animal so if you go
ahead and play the movie
oh is the movie not playing
excellent so um
what you were saying was the and i think
that was the wrong movie actually that's
going to come up later but anyway
i'm just going to go ahead and show you
what this looks like in the still images
um but what you'll see is what i was
pointing out here's the pancreas
and this mouse can spin here's the
actually here's the tumor right here in
all these images
these are the kidneys this other red
part that i'm pointing to
and then finally these are peritoneal
metastases that we're picking up this
little dot right here
so after we image we sacrifice or
euthanize the animal we can do bio
distribution which tells us the injected
dose per gram or gives us the
concentration in each of the organs then
of course we can do histology to confirm
that there was a tumor there and then
also that these little spots that were
taking up the agent were
actual tumors and metastases so that was
great
um and then from there we do a whole
bunch of mouse models and so
this is a human derived xenograph the l
three point uh l 3.6 pls that's
orthotopic so they're a cell line
planted in the pancreas of the tumor
um that's immunocompromised
damage the tumor
in the mouse and the mets and the
primary tumor
we also did a liver model so this is
splenic injection
uh of the tumor cells and then they they
migrate up to the liver and we were able
with two cell lines so the
ak-134s which are the transgenic the
cell lines from the transgenic animal
and pink ones which are the human
derived um line so both in an
immunocompetent and immunocompromised
we're able to see the liver metastases
so this agent right now has been cleared
by the fda we have actually injected one
patient with no adverse effects um and
so we're still in the process of
processing and understanding the data
but this agent is actually in clinical
trial so we're really excited on
and can't wait to see the outcome of the
clinical trial
but like i said these peptides aren't
just imaging agents we can also use them
to conjugate them to
other particles
for
for drug delivery and in this case we've
done this with liposome so this is a
targeted like liposome on the blue
and this is a dose escalation study
versus a controlled liposome versus the
blood pool for both what you can see is
that even after
168 hours we still have a two-fold
increase
or two-fold higher accumulation with in
the tumors with targeted
on liposome versus non-targeted
and in this case the drug that we're
delivering is a fluorescent small
molecule so we're not looking for a
tumor decrease we're just looking at how
much is being taken up
and those studies are ongoing but we're
really able to increase
the amount of drug delivered to these
tumors by using these liposome based
approaches
and then finally i just got this nih
funded but using uh aav for j aav adeno
associated virus for gene therapy so in
this case what we did is we have a wild
type aev and this is serotype eight
um versus a
ptp which is the peptide pancreatic
targeted peptide that we have and we
fuse that to the capsid protein of the
aav8 so again doing a viral display
like we did with phase display but this
time it's in the aev 8 protein
and then also
so that's transductional targeting but
for transcriptional targeting we've also
incorporated a pancreatic cancer
specific promoter atdc and so we have
two levels of control so in the upper
left that's the wild type virus and it's
just expressing luciferase under the cmv
reporter and what you see is liver and
some spleen involvement and in the upper
left there's no tumor so these animals
are p53
um but they're not activated so these
animals do not have um
these animals are not crossed they're
not um
crossed with the crew recombinase so
they are
they are uh they do not have a tumor and
so you see that but when you have when
you inject the targeted on
transductional and transcriptional
targeted the animals are not expressing
luciferase anywhere
however when you have the um
with the tumor
on but no targeting you still get the
liver
uptake and you get a little bit in the
pancreas but you still get the other
tumor or other tissues being targeted
but
in the targeted um the transcriptional
and transduction you're only seeing it
in the tumor so again this is a way now
replacing the cmv with a drug of choice
or a gene that would kill
um of choice we would be able to
hopefully do some therapy here so we're
pretty excited about that
or as we're studying things you could
start to imagine we have peptides and
i'll show you later for different
compartments in the tumor micro
environment so this would allow you to
knock in or knock out any gene um and
therefore any protein in that tumor and
study its effects and not doing the
transgenics um
per se
and so that's all well and good we have
these peptides but what does it bind to
and so this allows us to be able to
identify the targets it's not so easy to
just go ahead and deconvolute what those
peptides are binding to because it's
only a seven amino acid peptide and then
you go ahead you do the seven amino acid
peptide you do a blast search for
example and a lot of things pop up it's
it's not um
it's just the way that it is and so
we've developed this method uh phase
display based functional proteomics that
allows us to identify the binding
partners and so in the first step what
we do is we label the phage with biotin
and also a photoactivatable cross linker
so again this comes out of our ways of
using the phages now or phages materials
you incubate it with the with the cells
and you do this at four degrees to
minimize internalization
let the phage bind wash away phage that
that don't bind use a uv lamp to
activate the cross linker lice and then
incubate that with a biotinyl or
streptavidin coated uh dinell beets a
magnetic bead
allow those to incubate and bind
uh wash the beads break the crosslink so
elude it with dtt so reducing conditions
and then run the ele on a gel um
to
stain it with a mass spec compatible
silver stain cut out the unique band so
we also do control phage
and control cell lines so we're looking
at for the unique bands because it's
kind of messy
and we're working on cleaning that up
but you cut out the unique bands and
then
send those off for in-gel terrific
digest and mass effect sequencing and
what comes back is a report that
identifies what it's binding to and then
of course we validate so we take the
eluent that we didn't run out on the gel
then do a western blot using the
antibody of the protein that the mass
back identified and then also either
make recombinant purified protein or
just go and purchase it if it's
commercially available and do an elisa
on purified protein and so that way
we're able to validate
so from this screen we were able to
identify the binding partners of the
things with decent affinity and
specificity what i want to draw your
attention to is some of these that were
already known for example in x and a2
and in fact that correlates loosely with
gem cytobean resistance
um so an xna2 is a marker of gencitabine
resistance but the other thing i want
you to focus on is this protein plectin
so clone 27 the peptide that binds to
pancreatic cancer that we're doing
clinical trials it's binding partners
this protein plectin
so what is plectin well it's kind of an
interesting little guy and it's not so
little it's a 500 kilodalton
intracellular protein that links the
cytoskeleton
um and it has a genetic disease and so
if there's a mutation in plectin it
leads to epidermolysis bullosa which is
a skin blistering disease and that's
because one of its functions is to link
the hemidesmosomes and to anchor these
skin cells to other skin cells through
beta 4 on the integrand beta 4 alpha 6
beta 4. so what i told you before is
that this protein has to be accessible
and it has to be on the cell surface the
phage cannot
cross the plasma membrane unless it's
through an active process
and so what we found through extensive
experimentation is that in normal cells
like skin in the genital urinary tract
plucked in a cytoplasmic that's its
normal place it's in it does normal
functions however in pancreatic cancer
it is expressed uh and displayed on the
cell surface and so we've done extensive
um tissue microarray validation it's not
present in normal pancreas or chronic
pancreatitis pain in one or two sixty
percent of
pan and three lesions are positive for
plectin
uh 41 out of 41 of the pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma patients were positive
on in the liver lymph node and
peritoneum they are negative for plectin
except for when pancreatic cancer has
metastasized so the metastases are
positive but those tissues are negative
we've also looked at looked at cis so i
said that that was a high risk patient
population and so 94 percent of the time
it's a 94 positive predictive value that
if you have plectin one um you have
a
a high grade dysplasia or a cancer in
those in those specimens
plectin is also found in other cancers
notably bile duct uh cholangiocarcinoma
that makes sense the bile duct and the
pancreas doctor very close to each other
um it's an ovarian cancer non-small cell
lung carcinoma colon cancer but notably
absent in prostate cancer so we actually
use prostate cancer as a negative
control
for a lot of our studies
um and it has important roles so i won't
get into the gory details this is all
published in a pnas paper from 2013
but on plectin has 11 isoforms eight of
which are coding and so my grad student
did a lot of work making lentiviral
constructs for all of these and what she
found is that the isoforms 1a and 1f the
two isoforms that bind to the integrand
beta 4
are the ones that have function in the
in the tumor so when we knock down those
proteins we get a decrease in
proliferation invasion and
invasion and migration
um and then she can go ahead and rescue
them by expressing those proteins
um again this is showing invasion and
migration
and on another level that loss of the
plectin actually decreases tumor growth
and tumor aggressiveness and so in both
the l 3.6 pl and the um
in the cell lines the mouse cell lines
um from those transgenics when we make
stable knockdowns of those cells which
is actually really difficult so if we
leave them in culture too long they will
start to re-express if you will the the
cell culture or the whole cell culture
will start to re-express plectin so we
have to knock it down and then use them
right away um
but if we put these into the pancreas of
these animals and then look at them at
various time points
we can reduce the morbidity due to the
pancreatic cancer or mortality due to
the pancreatic cancer and also we get
less metastases
from this in both the immunocompromise
and the immunocompetent and these both
of these are very aggressive cell models
and so usually we have to euthanize
these animals 10 days after implantation
which is why
or these animals all die
so many days after implantation
they really quickly so these animals are
they actually die it's not just that we
are euthanizing them
um
and that's not happening with this so it
seems to be
an important protein
and other people have since published
some things on different cancers so
plectin has been shown to have a it's a
prognostic marker for head and neck
squamous cell carcinoma it's in
esophageal cancer and also in colon
cancer and so uh it's these studies all
confirmed our original findings so then
we started thinking well how is plectin
on the cell surface
um and we started thinking about this in
terms of exosome so there was this paper
published uh in 2008 by rister celly at
all
and it looked at the
protein components of an exosome and so
what we found that was really
interesting is the blue arrows are
pointing to the phage cone so these are
proteins that we identified through our
phage cones vnx and a2 histone 2a
and enolase 1. i don't have an arrow to
it but enolase
and
what was interesting is that filament
and spectrin are both proteins that
plectin binds to
so they're binding partners of plectin
and we looked at the methods and what
happened is is because plaquemine is
such an enormous protein if you don't
use a five percent gel and uh allow it
to run for a long time it doesn't run in
the gel so we suspect that they missed
plectin just because they they were
using a large
um gradient gel um so it really just
didn't get into their analysis
and so here's the exosomes uh the
membranes bought in um they then form an
early endosome they then go into the
multivesicular endosomes the rab27b and
rab27a are helpful in this and then
this multivesicular
body the mve goes and fuses with the
plasma membrane and then it releases the
exosomes
so exosomes have been shown to be really
important for cell cell communication
they have their they have function in
normal cells dendritic cells make a lot
of these melanosomes that's how melanin
is spread from cell to cell so there's a
lot of normal exosomes are normal
of these small bodies
but in cancer they've been shown to
enhance cell cell communication between
the tumor and its micro environment and
contribute to aggressiveness and so what
we did is we just isolated exosomes from
three cell lines
and also from tumors that were growing
in the
the orthotopic
on pancreas in the animal and we were
able to isolate exosomes from both of
them and they both were positive for
plectin and these exosomes had very
similar characteristics to what risk
cervicelly
and colleagues had seen and so when we
knocked down plectin what we discovered
though and we were doing em just to see
what would happen is that actually
plectin uh
without plex or with plectin the
membranes are very they're invaginated
there's lots of invader podia but
without plect plecting the membranes
become more uh quiescent kind of like
the human pancreatic ductal epithelium
so more normal pancreas cells and so we
actually quantitated this and the
concentration of exosomes in the media
of um
of cells conditioned media were
significantly lower when we knocked out
plectin and it was on part of knocking
out rap27 a and b both proteins that
have been previously shown to be
important for exosome formation so that
was exciting and then when we go ahead
and we add these exosomes to cells we
can get an increase in invasion and
migration of just
the different a c6 which is a cancer
line a glioma cancer line but also the
nih-3 t3s which are transformed
fibroblast line but still it was
exciting that these plectin positive
exosomes could
could
change the function
um and then there's a lot of other data
that i'm just going to skip through but
suffice it to say if you look at the
pnas paper that
a lot of a significant portion of the
cell surface plectin is due to exosomes
coming back and binding
plectin positive exosomes coming back
and binding to the cell surface so when
we incubate cells that are normally
plected minus on the cell surface with
plectin positive exosomes you get the
ability of the plectin antibody or
plectin peptide to now bind to those
cells where it didn't bind before
and also um
in and also you get these increases in
invasion migration not so much when you
have the plected negative exosomes so
when you normalize for number of
exosomes so you just use a lot more uh
media together the plectin minus
exosomes uh you don't get plucked in on
the cell surface um and then we did some
in vivo experiments where
we injected so tumors that were
either
just the gray line which are just the
l 3.6 is where the control on sh
or
with the rab27 knockdowns which
decreases exosomes but we've shown that
when you knock out rab27 a or b you do
not decrease plectin expression you just
decrease the amount on the cell surface
and you decrease the number of exosomes
um and so with those knockdowns you get
a decrease in the tumor growth and so
that's what that had been shown before
too is that exosomes are important for
tumor growth but then when we injected
either plected negative exosomes the
same number of plucked and negative or
plucked and positive exosomes you didn't
rescue the ability of the tumors to grow
however when you injected the plective
positive exosomes we actually got on
more growth more aggressive growth so
there's something about plectin um
and whatever it's binding to that is
dictating uh the aggressiveness in in
these exosomes so we did proteomics
analysis and there are significant
differences between the proteome of a
plective plectin positive exosome and a
plectin minus exosome
so in the last few minutes that i have
one of the tumor micro environment so we
can do screens on a whole bunch of
things spark is important it's secreted
protein acidic and rich in cysteine it
dictates the
fibronectin and collagen dis
layering in the tumor it's also
associated with a lot of aggressive
tumors not just pancreatic cancer we've
been able to identify new spark ligands
that bind to spark we can make uh
nanoparticles that allow us again to
deliver things to the spark
um so here's the
the uh animals on the left are have the
tumors that are spark positive these are
the targeted nanoparticles and the
animals on the
the right are the
the non-targeted these are the same
animals so we can actually with this
optical imaging we can tell the
difference between the two fluorophores
so the spark positive nanoparticles are
in one wavelength the spark negative
animals are in a the spark non the
non-targeted
nanoparticles are in another wavelength
and so using
um the same animal we can inject the
same
uh
we can inject the
two nanoparticles and then compare and
contrast
um and then three hours post injection
uh so that was the primary that was the
sub q tumor we also did a bone
metastasis and so the animal on on the
left side
there is a bone metastasis and the spark
agent is picking it up right here but
the animal on the right
has
does not have
a tumor in its leg and so
um
and then here's the h and e for the
spark expression so again we're able to
image the spark positive tumors um and
then we can also image uh metastasis in
the lung so if you go ahead and just
play the video here you can just see the
metastases from this animal model in the
lawn
so again this is superimposed with a ct
so we can get anatomic uh imaging so the
the uh colored um green and reddish halo
things are the agent and the the rest is
a ct
so from there we're also looking at
different expressions of molecules so
one of my colleagues jill slack davis
has been working on ovarian cancer and
what she's found is that vcam is
expressed in the
peritoneum before ovarian cancer
metastasizes to the peritoneum
and they're became positive and also
vcam is a marker of tamoxifen resistance
and so we were able to use a vcam
targeted fluorescent agent and also a
spec agent to image uh in vivo
non-invasively
vcam expression in the tumor micro
environment and we're using this model
to study the micro environment and its
role in ovarian metastases
we were also able to monitor the
therapeutic response
with this vcam targeted agents so there
were cell lines that were
resistant to cis platinum versus cell
lines that were sensitive to cisplatin
and what we were able to see is that
the vkm expression increases when they
are cisplatin resistant
but it stays roughly about the same when
they're be when they're cis platinum
sensitive
um and finally the very last slide
before i'll take your questions is we
are also looking at the immune system
and the interaction of the immune cells
with on the endothelium in the tumor
we're looking to re-engineer those
vessels so what we were able to do is
label
t cells um inject them into an animal
that had a melanoma on its ear and then
track them um using video so again
non-invasive and the ear is very thin
and so we were able to do this
uh but what you're seeing here is here's
the normal vessels of the ear skin
here's the tumor associated vessels you
can see the tortuosity
on the right hand side of that image
and then
we before we inject via tail vein the
primed uh t cells we get our our video
ready and so
you don't move the microscope and what
we can see is right after injection
we're already getting t cells into this
and then what we can do is we can follow
this along on in the video so in this
red arrow that you see starting here
that t cell started right here that's
when it came into our frame and we could
track it up along here and we can
get metrics for this so average distance
and then in the d panel what you're
seeing is
all those red arrows are pointing to t
cells and we can get the average
distance to nearest in-plane vessels so
we can see how far they transmigrated
in the eye panel you can start to see
rolling versus adherence so we can look
at the interactions and as we do
different therapies how does it change
and then here in the a and b panel
that's again the fluorescence optical
imaging of the ear this is in vivo
non-invasive and what you're seeing is
that all these arrows are pointing to
the red hot spots or the lymph nodes so
the the t cells are getting in the lymph
nodes um and then you can see a few of
them in the arrow pointing with the t
that's the tumor so we're really excited
about working on this this is a
collaboration with vic englehart here at
uva
so with that being said there's a
picture of the lab and uh in the last 10
minutes i'm happy to take any questions
that you guys might have so please uh
please submit them and i will i will
answer questions
all right so no one has any questions
you
uh so um we got a question have you used
the targeted nanoparticle for therapy
um we are starting to um
we actually have in a different in uh in
a different incarnation so we've been
loading small molecule drugs and testing
their efficacy so yes yes we have used
it for for therapy
and we've been working on
these are liposome based nanoparticles
and so we've been working on each drug
has its own loading conditions and such
and so
you have to do a little bit of work on
loading them
and looking at release kinetics
potentially changing lipid formulation
depending on when you want it to release
but
but yes we have used the nanoparticles
for therapy
well i guess i if there's no other
questions
i think everybody should by now have
i've been able to type in
and figured out how to do it but uh
there's no other questions then i'll
i'll thank you guys all now for
listening and then sign off um and then
if you
have any questions you can go ahead and
email me and i'm happy to email
collaborate have a discussion um
this is the fun part of science so again
thank everybody again and
i look forward to your emails
you